je suis ravie je me demande même si j'ai
encore nager tellement ça fait longtemps
que tu peux aller à la piscine premiers
plongeons depuis six mois
les habitués de la piscine de mignot à
poissy retrouve le bassin extérieur
considérée comme un équipement de plein
air oui ça fait beaucoup de bien on est
super contents que soient rouverts ouais
effectivement j'attendais avec
impatience je regarde je check est
régulièrement le site et d'exiger que
c'était ouvert
j'ai repris 2 tu tapes ici tu ressens
énormément qu'un de les piscines seront
pratiquement toutes fermées enfin toutes
celles qui n'ont pas de bassins
extérieurs
donc on attendait que ça très content
cela faisait depuis six mois que ça
avait fermé voilà ça fait du bien au
mental c'est entre 1h15 et une heure et
demie pour pour le plaisir
ce sont seulement les nageurs de plus de
12 ans qui sont autorisés à venir
trois créneaux horaires sont possibles
chacun pouvant accueillir 84 personnes
maximum
messier de fluidifier aussi un petit peu
l'arrivée des clients c'est vrai que si
on avait une ouverture publique 2010
jusqu'à 18h30
la problématique qu'on a qu'on avait
c'est peut-être un afflux de personnes
entre midi et 14 heures et plus
forcément grand monde en plein milieu
d'après-midi et puisqu'on passe aussi en
rang réservation recommandée
les personnes voit très bien le taux de
remplissage qu'on peut avoir par créneau
masque désinfection des mains et qu'elle
vient d'individus à l'obligatoire
fléchage et code couleur pour les
entrées/sorties douche savonnée avant
d'aller dans l'eau un protocole
sanitaires strictes a été établi ce sont
aussi trois couloirs au lieu de 6 pour
éviter les croisements
on essaie de tourner à peu près une
vingtaine de personnes par lindo sachant
que c'est un bassin de 50 mètres donc ça
laisse beaucoup de place à partir de mai
la jauge devraient être augmentés à 200
personnes maximum
la pataugeoire quand elle rouvrira au
mois de juin si les conditions
sanitaires le permettent